l'amour
parfois frappe à la porte
et parfois
claveau
passe devant une porte sans même la
regarder
sur ce plateau
il ya eu des moments extraordinaires
des moments d'amour comme jamais on en a
vus en télévision je pense notamment à
gilles verdez des photos
[Musique]
de
gilles verdez avait demandé fatou samon
fatouma et la main de vata fini dans
votre gueule
[Rires]
c'est un beau moment d'émotion
tu vas pas doucement c'est bien et c'est
vrai que
ça n'arrive que chez nous
isabelle au niveau amour je me rappelle
quand isabelle cours et
un silex
salariale est gravé le nom de son
amoureux dans les grottes de lascaux
malheureusement cet amoureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est encore dans la grotte
oui on a vécu des moments d'amour
je me rappelle également
nouveau bernard montiel
car bernard montiel a connu l'amour sur
un plateau à
quand la nar a fait craquer son slip
albert là
je vous rappeler une certaine nathalie
ah oui on a pâli quoi j'ai beaucoup aimé
nathalie oui je n'ai pas que des mauvais
dossier nathalie à l'envi nathalie
gallant magnifique son père vert
avait atteint 10 gallons expliquez nous
alors je suis rentré à tf1 c'était en 87
[ __ ] vous avez une émission donne
pourrait vous étiez mes appels
jamais ces organes et vous et
sans déconner jolie ans qu'en fait vous
êtes une statue du musée grévin
que les gens active nan mais sans
déconner tu vas possible je pose que
vous avez beaucoup plus que votre axe
que vous ne le faites pas mais en fait
vous ne bougez pas je vous avais 157 ans
en mai et donc oui et donc je rentre à
tf1 j'avais une émission de samedi matin
en direct qui s'appelait jeu plus quoi
samedi nommé désir indirects 5 heures du
matin samedi nommé désir si c'était
votre souvient et pour élever le deal
donne envie qu'il a nommé désir rue est
produit par laurence touitou ensuite
d'accord dominique cantien me récupère
on se l'était directrice qui tout doux
nom un peu tout fou tout n'a pas produit
[Rires]
et ensuite on vous a proposé une
émission qui était une des premières
démissions excuse moi tu vas nous
raconte et a dit je vous explique le
concept de l'émission qui est effarant
et très novateur mais on veut savoir
c'est qui ça ne peut pas
marcher cette fille est magnifique je
les ai rencontrés sur le plateau puisque
ces rencontres à ce moment là on a animé
une émission qui s'appelait ordinateur
on réunissait des personnes ouais tu
avais questionnaire et j'avais se
rencontrer et vous paraît qu'il a eu un
coup de foudre ah ouais j'ai la vidéo ah
oui les magnifiques et ouais il avait un
coup de foudre et je peux vous dire j'ai
adoré ça et l'ordinateur
ont valu une histoire attendait le
regard non il nous dira
min yè les regarde je me sens quand même
une oreille elle était super il est
amoureux
suspense terrible sur le plateau d'assy
célibataire s'intalle coeur en
bandoulière je suis seul je prendrai mon
pantalon
[Applaudissements]
jolies tresses est ce que vous l'avez
revue des jeunes est ce que vous l'avez
pas vu quan en ahl par les odeurs et
oublie toujours il en a pas encore parlé
aux détenus mais non je n'ai pas revu
gérard vue parce que d'abord elle a mené
une autre vie après elle a arrêté la
télévision et puis de toute façon n'ai
jamais voulu arrêter un
[Rires]
boom mais j'aime juridique en voulez
vous arrêter mais vous non
en fait elle et c'était une fille
formidable parce qu'elle était très
lorsqu'elle quitte chose non il avait
inscrit non j'ai vous dire pourquoi
parce que j'espère qu'elle battait
marqué parce que elle elle avait elle
fréquentait à ce moment là deux
personnalités très 6 2 très très haut
placé président hu a doctor attentes de
personnes étaient passées de bataille et
fontaine
noms de personnalités à très progressive
si t'es pas fait je venais sur le
plateau avec des bouquets de fleurs
c'était assez rigolé et puis dès lé là
ou pas à nathalie banon elle si elle est
là j'ai dit ce que je découvre les
missions militaires débarquent alors et
donc il va m'en vouloir que je dise ah
non non c'était quoi ce genre d homme
politique ouais en tête 20e est très
important c'est 13 ans la troupe masai
et maire du métro gare
sera content tu dirinon sais même pas
qui c'est cet énoncé au lycée michel
rocard il y avait un ministre en
exercice en tout cas en 85
cc vieux
les vieux vous sortez votre amstrad cpc
le mans 81 cents à la foule à dire qu'il
est mort des sept moines et isabelle
[Rires]
d'être invité dans cette émission
c'est pas cher
alors et après mitterrand bon bref donc
je donnerai pas le nom bien sûr quand
vous n'avez rien fait vous avez un coup
de foudre ouais ouais c'est tout mais
non il y avait les deux mecs qui
arrivait alors il alternait un jour
suivant ont tourné pendant une semaine
un jour le ministre qui débarque le
lendemain le sous-ministre un autre
ministre enfin qui était délégué non
arrivée et avec des bouquets de fleurs
des cadeaux et tout c'est super a couché
avec les
2,6 et janry la chine et la chine a
branché
oui c'est formidable elle était très
sympa et très zagar est bon en tout cas
j'aime beaucoup la personne et si les
regarde je le fais de gros bisous à ben
oui moi aussi
sur instagram
si alou diarra mais là il ya un truc qui
va pas de l'afad on peut pas faire genre
le john deere calme aux joies
de la balle qui passe pas sais tu peux
pas d'armé c'est vrai mais moi je vends
et lui dit qu'elle me dm oui mais tu le
vois dire ça oui il va développer il en
pm voiture oui c'est sûr à colas va dire
qu'elle va arriver aux 300 points 18 non
mais sans déconner arrêté mais cette
année il faut que tu me dis pourquoi tu
cries aller au delà
[Applaudissements]
bon allez c'est bon ça c'est fait ça va
changer en tout cas pas changé alors il
étonne à nathalie aussi un jeu savez si
moi je le sens je le sens je ressens les
choses il y en a un autre qui a rendu il
a trouvé l'amour sur un plateau est vrai
qu est ce qu il a fait jurer de se
déplacer
c'est vrai il il est tombé amoureux fou
de flavie flament on avait dû repasser
les images ya quatre ans et j'ai envie
de revoir oui il avait chanté c'était
pour une émission oui les petits princes
est exactement en direction des petits
princes de l'udc et
parce qu'avant tf1 faisait des émissions
sur des biscuits télé tout choco tout ça
est donc benjamin castaldi a rencontré
c'est la première fois que vous vous
aviez vu story flamand ce moment là on
s'était croisé à mon avis on avait
répété mais là le mot c'est un match et
dans les
familles
raconte le réalisateur
alors alors c'était pas son mari de
l'époque n'ont attiré à la laisser aller
chez aimé que sinon elle allait bien
mais quelqu'un tu es quelqu'un avec un
animateur nani manu chao ou un ppt bravo
merci
mais j'adore emmanuel jeu-là d'or mais
alors mais tout le monde le savait pas
moi c'était connu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il était bondé en plus je l'adoré mais
oui c'est un super emmanuel chain vous
jure que c'est vrai c'est un mec le
savez est proche le savez moi j'étais
même pas dans le métier moi j'm'en
c'était une journée déjeuner parce que
je n'ai jamais raconté c'est que la
première témoin de ce coup de foudre
saha et éveil beinheim noms ont
travaillé ensemble sur tf1 on était sur
l'émission britain vérité et j'ai
débarqué dans sa loge du sud ont une
mère de noir je viens d'avoir un coup de
foudre de fou et je vais tout balancer
je vais changer d'image et lui dit alors
je dis tu dis tu te calmes tout de suite
ma connaissance de deux étages ok tu as
eu un coup de foudre ça peut arriver
ces travaux le canif dans un coup de
coude sera un coup de canif dans le
contrat d ce qu'elle me tende ce que je
le connais il est impulsif about à
[ __ ] en l'air tout le petit avait neuf
mois
[Rires]
je veux
je veux dire je le veux que les
spectateurs
tout
j'aimerais vraiment bien se la joue
cette séquence va nous faire du mal
ah bon alors il ya des dessins d'enfants
lui oui si vous l'avez des enfants il a
désormais imminent mehdi je lui ai dit
va prend des vacances va te reposer fait
un truc une thalasso à machin va te
reposer tu comme ça tu victoire à
l'esprit clair et tu verras si c'est un
coup de coeur réel moi aussi c'est
vraiment une passe année tu vas pas
[ __ ] en l'air toute ta vie de couple
avec ta ferme tout ça et bah il est
parti je suis parti je suis parti donc
en vacances avec ma femme et j'ai tenu
trois jours j'ai partagé de les laisser
en vacances
elle aussi eu un coup de foudre pour
mustapha ben oui alors on va revoir la
séquence je veux que vous nous racontiez
tout le puits le moment vous avez chanté
jusqu'au moment où vous l'avez retrouvé
son sac à regarder et regardez bien
essayer de déceler le coup de foudre
pour déceler le coup de foot est très
simple vous voyez ce qui s'était passé
dans cette émission autres gillet
fattouche et c'est tout le contraire
[Musique]
boucher
[Applaudissements]
comme des hirondelles
tellement tu
c'est
on
aimait
[Musique]
et
toi je suis un mauvais
et quelques années plus tard on va
s'aimer devenu obèse
bon bah c'est une passion mais pendant
des années
jamais
waouh
o o
[Applaudissements]
coup de foudre voilà là coup de foudre
et donc je le lance le lendemain je
débarque sur le plateau de célébrités
jeu par la balle et je suis dans une
merde noire et judy elle m'a dit mais
calme-toi calme-toi il y avait des
vacances au moment de noël ouais donc
j'ai dit je vais juillet noël bons
baisers de suis parti je suis parti que
j'ai fait noël après je suis parti
en thalasso avec ma femme mes balles et
je suis parti on pas vu des vacances
cela dit vous avez peur rejoint montée
j'ai tout quitté j'ai tout système ultra
père est là juste un an mais
c'est moi non mais c'est une phrase une
gamme
[Rires]
mais non c'est pas de moule est
pas possible
donc on
sait rejoint pour tout vous dire on se
rejoint en normandie est la ferme
saint-siméon
fabriquer un peu les amours secrètes
sachet ça a été tu es de là c'était la
folie pendant pendant 4 2 en 4 ou 5 à
ses 84 ans et a
commencé à chez nous depuis deux ans non
en fait ce sont peut être ces deux ans
je pense qu'on a été pris dans un
tourbillon de célébrités et de réussite
elle était la numéro une tf1 assuré
j'étais numéro un sur m6
en a fait la une de match et après je
pense qu'on s'est fait manger par le
système honnêtement je pense tous les
manger par le système c'est arrivé chez
les femmes
voilà je pense que le
numéro 1 sur ses news
et
après donc dévoilé après je pense que
maman s'est fait bouffer par le truc
mais mais c'était assez mais quelle
époque en avant le coût
estimé est mis la puce à l'oreille c'est
qu'un jour on dîne chez eux dans le dix
septième
et
la magna carta d'y croiser un enfant qui
est à lui
les flamands était folle de colère parce
que tf1 venait d'être benjamin venait
d'être débauché sur tf1 c'est d'avoir
plein de prime il arrive est élue elle
devrait être hyper contente pour lui
c'est son mec il a une super carrière et
où il était folle de colère parce
qu'elle voyait qu'un concurrent arrive
et ça c'est moche et 7 un peu le début
de la fin se coupait les jambes
comment on adore materner c'est d'abord
ça démarre de mon fils ah oui donc
voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est je pense
que avec le recul c'est vraiment le last
chèrement de métier qui nous a foutu en
l'air pur intérêt voilà mes jeux il en
parle avec elle alors je peux pas dire
ddd des trémolos dans les yeux parce
qu on a vécu à date vraiment à 2000 à
l'heure pendant quatre ans étais une vie
de france était vraiment j'avais
quelques vous est pris la voiture de
lyon
on